Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to have an AI write a story
for us, and even do our coding exam materials.
And the coolest thing is that both
of these will be done by the same AI.
How? Well, OpenAI’s GPT-3 technique is capable of
all kinds of wizardry as long as it involves text
processing. For instance, finishing our sentences,
or creating plots, spreadsheets, mathematical
formulae, and many other things. While their
Dall-E 2 AI is capable of generating incredible
quality images from our written descriptions.
Even if they are too specific. Way too specific.
Now, today, we are going to play
with GPT-3, the text AI that just
gained an amazing new capability. And
that is, editing and inserting text.
And if you think that this doesn’t sound
much, well, check out these examples.
Let’s start a story. Today’s the big day! It says.
Now, the AI sees that the name of the section
is high school graduation, and it infers, quite
intelligently that this might be a message
from a school to their graduating students. So
far so good, but this was possible before too.
So what’s new here? Well, hold on to
your papers, and now, let’s do…this!
Oh yes. Change the story. Now, we don’t know why
is this the big day, but we know that the next
section will be about moving to San Francisco,
and…oh my! Look at that! It understood the whole
trick, and rewrote the story accordingly. But,
you know what? If we wish to move to Istanbul
instead - not a problem. The AI gets that one
too. Or, if we have grown tired of the city life,
we can move to a farm too, and have
the AI write out story for that.
Okay, that was fantastic, but when it comes to
completion, I have an idea. Listen. How about
pretending that we know how to make hot
chocolate. Fill in the last step, which is,
you know, not a great contribution, and let the AI
do the rest of the dirty work. And can it do that?
Wow, it knows exactly that this is recipe,
and it knows how to fill that in correctly.
I love it. The put hot chocolate
part is a bit of a copout,
but you know what, I’ll take it. From the
recipe, it sounds like a good one. Cheers!
Now, let’s write a poem about GPT-3. There we go!
It rhymes too, checkmark. And now, let’s ask the
AI to rephrase it in its own voice. And…yes! It is
able to do that, while carefully keeping the rhyme
intact. And when we ask it to sign it, look.
We get a letter to humanity. How cool is that?
Now, onwards to coding. And this is
where things get really interesting.
Here is a piece of code for computing
Fibonacci numbers. Now, translate it
into a different programming language. Wow, that
was quick. Now, rewrite it to do the same thing,
but the code has to fit one line. And here comes
my favorite: improve the runtime complexity
of the code. In other words, make it more
efficient. And there we go. Now, clearly,
you see that this is a simple assignment, yes.
But. Make no mistake, these are fantastic signs
that an AI is now capable of doing meaningful
programming work. And if you have a friend who
conducted coding interviews, show it to them. I
reckon they will say that they have met plenty
of human applicants who would do worse than this.
If you have your own stories, you know what to do.
Of course, leave them in the comments
section, I'd love to hear them.
And, if you have been holding
on to your papers so far,
now, squeeze that paper because here comes the
best part. We will fuse the two previous examples
together. What does that mean? Well, we will use
the hot chocolate playbook and apply it to coding.
Let’s construct the start and the end of
the code, and hand it away to the AI. And,
yes, once again, it has a good idea as to
what we are trying to do, it carefully looks
at our variable names and fills in the key
part of the code in a way that no one will
be able to tell that we haven’t been doing
our work properly. What a time to be alive!
So, an AI that can write a story for us, even in a
way that we only have to give it the scaffoldings
in the story, and it fills in the rest. I
love it. So cool! And it can help us with
our coding problems, and even help us save a ton
of time massaging our data into different forms.
What an incredible step forward in
democratizing these amazing AIs.
So, what would you use this for? What do you
expect to happen a couple more papers down the
line? Please let me know in the comments
below. I’d love to hear your thoughts.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!